escale pascal tu m'entends pascal papas
et mamans viennent d'arriver aux sports
d'hiver
oui tout va bien tout va bien écoute moi
pascal avant que grand mère vient de
s'occuper de vous je voudrais que tu
fasses à manger pour toi et ta petite
soeur crippa youpi craybas youpi pas
femme à l'autre a dit écoute pascal
voilà ce que tu fais toujours le frigo
tu as dit reste dans le frigo et ajusta
fait réchauffer les rays je vais faire
la cuisine
qu'est ce que tu veux faire comme
cuisine des pâtes
vous pensez que vous allez manger toute
la semaine des pâtes des pâtes à la
bolognaise
qu'est ce que c'est sain c'est une
recette de ton copain budoni et que cr7
et pâtes avec de la viande mais où vous
avez trouvé d'avion cebu denis qui l'a
ramené dans son cartable
alors il a gardé cette viande toute la
journée à l'école dans son cartable
elle commence à bien me demande bien
comment les sa viande correct elle est
correcte d'accord mais qu'est ce que
vous mettez avec cette viande la crème
fraîche qui était dans le frigo
ça fait deux mois que dans le frigo ouah
elle est déjà dans l'eau avec les pâtes
la viande il dit
parfois vous donniez pas ça vous niez
pas se mouiller
tout ya sa place tout cas sa place à
thomas halloween 2011 unis pendant tu
t'appelles biniou emilio n'est pas un
méchant garçon toi ou alors par loi tepa
non regardant la casserole dis moi ce
que tu vois la casserole les pattes
rose c'est normal avec de la viande noir
oui je viens dans de l'eau qui joue donc
à les jaunes au tamis du safran d'accord
tamise tu fais plus rien maintenant tu
carrie pas trop car il quand même à
l'eau qu'est ce qu'il fout là j'entends
ces bouquets ce qui est vous le chocolat
et pourquoi vous mettez du choco dans
les pattes maintenant annoncer le
dessert c'est à part celle des serveurs
non mais qu'est-ce qui vous chante
enseigne la casserole et molle mais où
vous l'avez trouvé cette casserole sous
l'évier
mais souligner c'est fou les récepteurs
qui sont classiques
alors forcément sur les mettez sur le
feu fo la casserole parfois pascal
passera pascal hirabe à ce chocolat et
plastique fondu avec pascal pascal
pascal postale ne t'affole pas ne
t'affole pas si elle le téléphone du
bout des doigts
si tu arrives à décoller le téléphone va
dans l'armoire et prendra non surtout ce
salon vad dans la chambre de papaye
durement tu tires un draps du lit tuées
suite téléphone et tu es pense tous qui
dégouline fais toi et départ budoni dit
où il qu'est ce qui à tour hier derrière
elles sont cuites et par pascal pascal
était pas prend la place de budoni
devant les pattes alors dis-moi où ils
en sont les pains il ya tout fumé
écoute moi pascal prendre cette plonge
la roue hasard dans les pattes est il
une patte tirs
ça fait un bloc équipe à pascal gires
dire tu as une pas de la thune à la pâte
à une patte là bon alors qu'août là
n'ont fait la goutte est à boudry
il m il m il faut oublier pas il est
bien alors pascal vous écoutez bien mais
quand vous mangez les pas debout les
pieds dans plastique grand-mère harry
rohmer arrive